- Hi everyone.
Welcome to our Homeroom livestream.
Very excited about the
conversation we're about to have.
But I will start with my
standard announcements
reminding everyone that we,
Khan Academy, we're a 501(c)(3).
We're not for profit.
We can only exist with donations
from folks like yourself.
So, if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation.
I'll also wanna give a special shout out
to several corporations and organizations
that really stepped up over
the last several months
when they realized that Khan Academy
was already running at
a deficit pre-COVID,
and our deficit only accelerated
as we had almost two to three
times the number of users
and we tried to accelerate
a whole series of programs
to support people through school closures.
So, special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, and Novartis.
Although, even with their support,
their very generous support,
we continue to run at a deficit.
So, once again,
if you represent a
corporation, or even yourself,
every donation makes a difference.
So, with that, I'm very excited
to introduce our next guest,
Dr. David Sinclair, professor
at Harvard University.
David, thanks for joining.
- Thanks, Sal. Good to see you again.
- Likewise.
Folks don't...
I mean, I have talked about in the past
I have some fringe eating habits,
and so I'm definitely very in
kind of the health
world on certain things,
but a lot of people don't know
that I've actually followed your work
for many, many years,
and we'll get into it.
But it's probably best
coming out of your own mouth.
What is the focus of your research?
And also, what got you into it?
Why do you wanna devote your
life to this area of research?
- Well, my passion is to extend
healthy lifespan of people.
I don't like people getting sick.
And so, I'm a scientist
at Harvard Medical School,
and we research what I
think is one of the biggest
biological and medical
problems of all time,
which is why do we get sick,
especially as we get older.
And we all know that our
bodies are capable of healing,
especially when we're young,
and the question is, why is that?
Why is it when you're young,
you can heal from a wound
or you don't get cancer or Alzheimer's,
but as you get older, you do?
And that's what we're
trying to figure out,
because if we can harness
that energy of youth
and maybe even turn back
the clock in our bodies,
I think it'll be the biggest
medical revolution of all time.
So, you asked me why do I do it.
Well, you know, I think
like a lot of people
I'd like to leave a legacy.
I'd like to have an impact,
make the world better than I found it.
My grandmother instilled
that in me especially.
But I'm also very curious,
and I think that trying to tackle
one of the hardest problems on the planet
certainly keeps me busy and
very entertained with my lab.
- And there's a lot in what you just said.
I mean, maybe the first thing
that I've always found it fascinating is
we're always caught up with
the diseases of the world,
you know, the big ones.
Cancer, heart disease, diabetes.
But you essentially just
view those as side effects
of another phenomenon, which is aging.
And what I find fascinating about that is
aging is such a part of what
it means to be not even human,
what it means to be a
species as far as we know it,
that we don't even question that
as being the actual cause of
all of these other things.
When did it click in your mind
that you could address aging itself?
And at the same time
there's all these other
you know, Ponce de Leon looking
for the fountain of youth,
and so there's...
How did you navigate that
kind of fear that, like,
"Wait, this does seem like
something really important,
"but if I start talking about aging,
"people are gonna think I'm Ponce de Leon
"or one of these folks
looking for eternal life"?
- Well, it was like that
when I first started.
This is going back to the
late '80s, early '90s.
Aging research was the
backwater of biology,
and to go into it in a serious
way was considered madness.
I had a number of mentors saying,
"Why would you do such a thing?"
Fortunately, during the 1990s
there were some real big breakthroughs.
A geneticist, one of which I worked for,
Lenny Guarente at MIT,
they got into it and said,
"Okay, let's just throw out
all these ideas why we age.
"Let's just look for what
genes control aging."
And what we found as a field
is that there are individual
genes that you can change
that dramatically extend
the lifespan of animals,
and yeast cells, which I was
working on as a kid in my 20s.
But what that told me and
anyone who would listen
was that the control of
aging is extremely simple.
Now, aging of course isn't,
in the same way a car will
wear out for many reasons.
But if there's a way to
slow that whole thing down
by changing one gene, it means
it's possible to have one day
a medicine that would slow down
and perhaps even reverse
aspects of the aging process.
And as you said, Sal, what's
so important about this
is that we throw away
our preconceived ideas
about what's natural.
Now, getting heart disease
and cancer 100 years ago
were natural, and very
little could be done,
and the same is going to be true for aging
once we accept as a medical profession,
and I'm a scientist not an MD,
but if we can accept that
one of the main reasons, if
not by far the biggest reason
that we get these diseases as we get older
is because of aging.
And the reason we haven't made
a lot of progress recently,
or up until now, is because
too many of us accepted it
as an inevitability.
Now, just to make a point,
I'm not saying that I'm Ponce de Leon
and I'm gonna give everyone immortality.
That's not the point at all.
And fortunately, our field has
gone ahead in leaps and bounds,
and now we're one of the most
respected areas of biology.
- Yeah, and (mumbling)
You mentioned some of
that earlier research
in Guarente's lab with,
in your case, the yeast.
What are some of what you would say
the seminal data points
over the last 20 or 30 years
that have started to
make people realize that,
"Wow, there's a lot here."
And I'm familiar with some of it,
but I'm guessing a lot
of people don't realize
what has already been done.
- Right.
I'm often shocked when I talk to people
who are not paying attention,
because they've got their
own lives to worry about,
how far we've come and
most people don't realize.
So, milestones.
We've known for, well, close to 100 years
that low-calorie diets can slow down aging
in animals, and seemingly
in humans as well.
You know, skipping a meal, having a fast,
it's always been considered healthy.
We didn't really know why.
And actually, you asked me why was I sure
that studying aging might be helpful.
Well, the main reason is that
when you give rats and mice
30% fewer calories in their life,
they live longer.
And they don't live longer
because they stay old.
They live longer because
they don't get cancer
and these other diseases of
rat aging, or mouse aging.
So, I knew that there was
something to be had there,
and if diet can do it,
surely we can make a
medicine to do that as well.
And we've made a lot of
progress towards that.
So, some of the milestones were...
So, the worm C. elegans.
That's a nematode worm.
There was a mutation in that called DAF-2
that extended its lifespan twofold.
And now actually you can
extend the worm by tenfold.
So, that's massive.
- You can...
You can extend a worm's
lifespan by a factor of 10.
From gene editing, is that how you do it?
Or is it with some molecule, or both?
- The most powerful ones are genetic,
but there are molecules
that now we can feed a worm,
even a drug that's on the market
for transplant rejection,
called rapamycin.
There are drugs that can
do what fasting, hunger,
used to only be able to do.
And another milestone
was we figured out that
changes to how genes are turned
on and off in yeast cells
contributes to their aging as well.
We learnt how to control that in mice.
We can now extend the
lifespan of mice genetically,
pharmacologically with molecules.
And one of the things that...
Well, there are a couple
of things I wanna say.
One is that these genes
are found throughout life.
They're found in yeast cells.
They're found in worms.
They're found in mice.
They're found in us.
So, we have longevity genes in our body.
And in fact, you can
look at certain variants
and see if you're more
likely to live longer.
And then the other big breakthrough
was the realization that
the way we live our lives
and the way animals in
the lab live their lives,
what they eat, whether they exercise,
if they eat the right foods,
they are actually turning on
these longevity genetic pathways.
So we've finally, I think
we have a model where
the reason that diet and
exercise is so good for us
isn't just because we stay lean
and because our blood flows.
It's actually because our
bodies have protective genes.
We call these longevity genes.
And as we get older, and if
we're lazy and we eat a lot,
they shut off,
but there are ways we
can turn them back on
by living the right lifestyle,
and hopefully one day
having access to medicines
that turn them on as well.
- And what I think the difficult
thing about this research
is obviously you can't study...
It takes too long to study a
human's lifespan. (chuckles)
How do you do that?
How do you translate the work
on the worms and the mice and the rats
to something that you
know works in humans?
- Well, there are business tricks to it.
What we've done,
and I've launched a number
of companies to do this,
certainly because a government grant
won't give us enough money to do that.
So the companies, we raise money.
We have traditionally started companies
where we see that these molecules
that could extend lifespan in humans
are also going to be useful
for diseases that need cures.
So, for instance,
there's a company that
is called MetroBiotech.
They work on raising a little molecule
in the body called NAD,
and it has potential
applications in rare diseases,
such as Friedreich's ataxia,
a genetic disease without a cure,
as well as even potentially
treating COVID-19.
We have a study that's
about to begin in that area,
and we think that that will
boost elderly people's ability
to fight against
infectious disease as well.
- And so, just to make sure
we're all on the same page.
The way you do this, obviously,
it'd be very hard to run
a randomized control trial
to see if you can get an average lifespan
from 80 to 83 years.
That research would take forever,
and none of us would be around, maybe,
to see what happens.
But instead, you look at
some of these diseases
that are associated with aging,
and there you can see, hey,
if this person gets this type
of therapy, this type of drug,
or this type of lifestyle change,
what happens to their-
what happens to those disease conditions.
- That's exactly right.
These molecules that I work
on, and other scientists,
they could be applied to
probably a hundred different diseases
that are related to aging,
and some not.
Sometimes these are just the
ability to boost the energy
and the repair systems of
even sick young people.
So, that's also important to realize
that this research isn't just about
keeping older people around.
It's about boosting the
body's natural defenses
against disease and disability
and promoting healing.
And you're right.
We can't do
probably a million people over 10 years.
There's no country in the world
that could even afford that.
But the hope is that if we
can get a drug on the market,
or even one that's already on the market,
and show that if you
look at 5, 10,000 people
over a few years,
we should be able to see that
they have health improvements,
or at the very least, slowing down of
the rate of diseases that occur.
And there's a lot of questions about NAD
that were even coming
before you mentioned it.
And for those super fans
of Khan Academy videos
or anyone who has been paying attention
in their freshman biology classes
or their high school biology classes,
you might recognize NAD from
respiration and ATP synthesis.
So, is that a coincidence?
For those who don't remember,
NAD shows up all the time
in the whole Krebs cycle.
So, explain. Is there a connection?
- Yeah, so, NAD is this little molecule
that cells use to carry out,
oh, about 400 or more enzymatic reactions.
It's one of the most boring molecules,
or at least it was up until the 2000s.
But what my colleagues and I realized
was that NAD levels also control
the body's survival networks.
And the lower your NAD levels, we believe,
the lower your defenses are.
And actually, as we get older,
and certainly, we know for sure
in animals as they get older
they have less NAD.
You can boost your NAD
levels somewhat back up
by doing exercise and skipping
a meal maybe once a day.
That is fairly well accepted.
But you can't expect
someone who's in a hospital
or who's elderly or sick
to go for a run easily, or skip meals.
So, what we need are
potentially NAD boosters.
This is a group of drugs that
I'm working on intensively.
And we're hopeful that
the same kind of things
that we see in mice in the lab,
some of them will happen in people.
And we'll probably know
in the next year or two,
or maybe sooner with the COVID-19 study.
But the kind of things we see
when we raise NAD levels
back up in old mice,
well, there's a lot of studies
way beyond what my lab has done,
but some of the things that I know of
from my lab are increased endurance.
So, old mice run farther. They
have much better blood flow.
They have better blood
flow in the brain as well,
not just their skeletal muscle.
They're resistant to heart attacks.
They have less inflammation.
Their respiration and their
mitochondria get revved up
like a young animal would.
So, there are lots of benefits
that we can see in mice.
We have a longevity
study that's in progress
that's looking promising.
I can't say much more just yet
because people in my lab will kill me.
But these are the kinda
things that hold out promise
that we can use some of
these changes in animals
to treat patients,
and ultimately, if a
drug gets on the market
for a particular disease,
my hope, my personal hope is that
now that drug can be tested
in many different areas,
many different disease areas by doctors,
and do their own clinical trials
in their own particular area.
And eventually, if everything goes well,
we could have millions or
tens of millions of people
being treated with these
drugs for not just diseases,
but eventually we'll see
that those people on the drug
hopefully will be less prone to diseases
and may even live longer.
- Yeah. And there's a ton of
questions here from Twitter.
AZ Latina, "Please ask Dr. Sinclair
"regarding the status of his research
"on NAD neurodegenerative diseases."
I don't know if that's the research
that your staff would kill
you for talking about.
Other people are talking
about NAD infusions.
And I'm gonna give a disclaimer here.
This is not a place to
get any medical advice.
This is not a place for any of that.
We're just having a conversation.
Please consult doctors,
et cetera, standard.
And then there's people
talking about other molecules
which I know you have done research on,
things like resveratrol,
or you know people who've
done research on resveratrol,
stair- I can never say it.
I know the molecule,
pterostilbene. (chuckles)
It starts with a P, pterostilbene.
You know how to pronounce
it better than I do.
So, I'll just group all of those.
Once again, I don't wanna
make any recommendations
of what people should or
shouldn't do with their lives.
People should do their own research.
But, I mean, you
mentioned NAD. How does...
I guess, if you could,
talk about what you know
about NAD and neurodegenerative diseases.
And also, how do you change
NAD levels in, say, a mouse,
or in, potentially, in human beings?
- Well, in mice there are a couple of ways
that NAD seems to work.
It will raise the levels
or activity of a set of
genes which we call sirtuins,
and many of those have been
show to be neuroprotective,
again in mice.
Now, you know, it's easy to
criticize these mouse studies,
but in defense, we have
to start somewhere.
But yeah, there's a lot of data
from other labs in particular,
a little bit from mine,
that you'll get neuroprotection
in a variety of diseases
from sirtuin activity,
from Parkinson's through to Alzheimer's.
And the second thing that happens,
which I mentioned earlier,
is that the mice get more
blood flow in their brain,
and we tracked that down to
the lining of blood vessels
actually become more youthful and grow,
in a healthy way, nothing
dangerous that we can tell.
And that makes me think
that there might be a chance
to use these so-called
NAD-boosting molecules
to treat vascular dementia,
which is a very pernicious
and common disease, actually,
with not much you can do.
So, I think that there's a lot of reason
to go and explore NAD boosters
in neurodegenerative diseases.
I haven't done any myself in humans.
I'm aware that there are some studies.
There's one in Parkinson's.
There's one, I believe it was also in ALS,
which I know is not neurodegenerative,
central but peripheral.
But yeah, I think that that's one area.
The area that I've more
particularly worked on
are muscle wasting
diseases, and also immunity.
- And what is...
How do you adjust the NAD
levels in a mouse or a human?
Is it an injection? Is it a pill?
Is it genetic? How do you do that?
- I have to be careful because
I'm not prescribing anything.
I'm just a PhD talking about science.
Let's make that clear.
But there are molecules
you can give to a mouse.
They're called NAD precursors.
These are the building blocks of NAD.
And we know from mouse
and some human studies
that I've been involved in
that they will raise
NAD levels in the body.
And the hope is that by doing that
we'll get those sirtuin defenses back up
to where they used to
be when you were young.
So, you can take pills. That's sufficient.
Some people do injections.
I don't know if they work or
not, but I hear about them.
But based on the literature,
we're right on the cusp of learning
what these NAD boosters are
capable of doing in people.
And many of them are natural molecules,
so that piques people's interest as well.
- Yeah.
You can imagine there's a
lot of questions about this.
Well, actually, there's some philosophical
and there's some medical questions.
So, let's go to the medical ones first.
So, Madonna Chicotta from Facebook,
she's 60 years old.
She's saying, "How many
years before we see
"a cocktail of drugs that extend lives?"
So, obviously, no one
can predict the future,
but you're really are the forefront
of where this research is.
What do you think things
are gonna look like
in 5 or 10 years?
When do you think this is
going to become very relevant
to the average person
watching us right now?
- There are, at last estimate,
20 companies who are either close to
or running clinical trials that
came out of aging research.
I'm hopeful that one or more of them
will be successful in the coming years.
How long until we have a cocktail?
It's probably more than that.
Drug development, as
I've learnt in my career,
is extremely tough, and
plenty of things can stop you.
So I'm always a bit cautious
about making predictions for the future.
There are drugs, actually,
that are on the market.
One I mentioned, which is rapamycin,
which is not something you'd take lightly
because it has some toxicity.
But there's another one, for
example, called metformin,
which anybody, almost
anybody who has type 2
or age-associated diabetes will know of.
It's also called Glucophage,
which lowers, tends to lower blood sugar.
It's one of the safer drugs
that you can get anywhere,
and it's also on the list of-
on WHO's list of essential
medicines for humanity.
So, why do I mention that?
Because if you feed it to
animals, they're healthier.
Mice can live longer.
And also, in studies that have looked at
10s of thousands of people on this drug,
those people on average tend
to be not just resistant
or doing better for type 2 diabetes,
but other diseases like
cancer, heart disease,
Alzheimer's, and even frailty.
It seems that those people
on the drug actually
have less chance than somebody
that never takes the drug.
So, the reason I mention that is that
there may be drugs already out there
that are going to be
part of a future cocktail
that people can go on in their mid-life,
you know, under doctor supervision
to make sure it's all safe.
I don't think we're that far away.
In terms of the science,
we're pretty much there.
- I know you're not a futurist,
but given your area of research
I'm sure people ask you questions,
so I will ask you a little
bit more about that.
When do...
I mean, do you think that in 30 years
we could be talking about a human lifespan
that is appreciably longer,
5, 10, 15 years longer?
- Yeah, I'd be surprised
if there wasn't a gain.
We live in a time where the
average lifespan is going down.
That's tragic and difficult.
But in 30 years when we're
over this current crisis
and this research that I'm talking about
and new areas that are emerging
have blossomed and given us medicines,
yeah, I think five years
is not that challenging.
Making it to 50 years,
you know, another 50
years, is much harder.
But there's some new
technologies that are exciting
that are complementary to this NAD work.
There's a way to delete old cells
and hurtful cells in the body.
These are called senescent cells.
There are some human
trials that look promising,
out of Mayo Clinic, for example.
- How do they do that?
How do they delete the senescent cells?
I've read about the issue
with senescent cells.
I know things like fasting
can help with the autophagy.
But how do you do that in a trial?
- Well, scientists have
looked for molecules
that either singly, or
typically in combination,
will kill a senescent cell but not hurt
the natural other healthy cells.
And the problem is that
those senescent cells
are just stuck in a zombie-like state
and you need to trigger
their death process.
So that's what those molecules do.
And when you do that, in a mouse at least,
they're a lot healthier.
And you don't need a lot of
senescent cells to cause havoc.
Jim Kirkland from Mayo Clinic
put just a dab of senescent
cells into a mouse
and it had more signs of aging.
So, that's one way.
The other area that's of interest
is actual reprogramming of
the body to be young again.
Not just slowing down aging,
but literally turning back
the clock of the body.
And the reason I bring up
that one in particular,
besides that we work on it,
is that that to me is a game changer.
If that works and it's safe in humans,
you could potentially roll back the clock
a decade in the body.
- What does that mean?
Is that...
I know decades ago people
talked a lot about telomeres,
which are kind of those, what
we thought were nonsense DNA
at the end of chromosomes.
What mechanisms are you talking about
when you talk about actually
turning back the clock?
- Yeah, so, I wrote a book about this
if anyone wants to follow
what I'm talking about.
Essentially, it's the idea that-
- I have a copy.
Right there.
- Thank you.
(Sal chuckles)
So, this was 20 years of my thinking
all rolled into one book.
And the idea, besides tips
on how to live longer,
the idea is a novel one, which is that
aging is primarily a loss
of information in the body
and that our old cells
just lose the ability
to read the right genes at the right time.
And we've known this occurs,
but very few people have thought
that that's what's driving
all these other problems.
And so, we've done experiments in my lab,
some of which we're about to publish,
which say that you can
cause aging to go forwards
by disrupting that information,
and then we can also reprogram cells
that get that information back again.
That's a game changer.
How is it possible to
restore the age of a cell?
Isn't that information gone forever?
If you break a compact disc or a DVD,
how are you possibly gonna
put that back together?
But what we're seeing in the lab
is that if you just turn
on some very specific genes
that are normally only on
when you're very, very young, in the womb,
the cells have the ability
to reset their age.
Not back to zero, but far
enough that the cells now
are behaving like they're young again.
And literally, when you measure their age,
and we have a way of doing that now,
there's a clock we can
measure in the cell,
they are literally young again.
- And I mean, that is, to
put it lightly, mind-blowing,
and I know you wanna speak
about it in very tempered ways
because it leads to very big
possibilities or questions,
many of which people have
been asking on social media.
Let's put our science fiction hat on.
Let's say that that works,
that that, you know, in 10,
15 years there are therapies
that go along the lines
that you are saying.
I'm almost afraid to
say what it could imply
because people would
think that I'm dreaming.
But in a world where you could,
I mean, I guess, you know, keeps-
You know, a 70-year-old who
looks like a 30-year-old
type of scenario,
and then therefore could
live much, much longer.
There's all these philosophical
questions people ask about.
From YouTube, Vivez Speaker says,
"If nobody aged, what
will happen to the earth?
"Will we have to build more land?"
Samara from Facebook is saying,
"I would be so worried about medication
"that increases longevity.
"We'd be tampering with
the circle of life."
I'm sure you get a lot of that.
How do you view it?
Or do you think this creates problems,
or this creates solutions,
or we don't know?
- Well, yeah, the last part
of my book talks about this,
about the good and the
bad that may come of this.
Now, the good, I think is, to me, obvious.
We're hoping to do our
first clinical trial
in under two years from now
to turn back the age of the eye.
And in mice, it's pretty easy.
We can turn back the age
of an old eye in a mouse
and restore its vision.
We can treat glaucoma,
pressure in the eye.
We can treat even optic nerve damage.
So, there are parts of the body
that I think will initially benefit.
And if it's your sister, or
your child, or your parent
who's been injured or has a disease,
I think that you'd be hard pressed to say,
"Oh, don't give them a medicine.
"It's the circle of
life. Let them suffer."
That's the easy part.
But if you wanna get into the ethics,
if we really are able
to turn back the clock
10, 20, 30 years in people,
yeah, what does the world look like?
And that's a very important question.
So, some of the work that I've
been doing is with economists
to see what happens as people live longer.
The important thing about
the economy I should mention
is that when people are old
and sick, it's a huge drain.
You know, in the U.S. we're spending
17% of GDP on healthcare,
and that's mostly because of the elderly.
If older people are still
productive and healthy
and then die fairly rapidly,
that's a massive saving,
in the trillions of dollars, for the U.S.
within even just the first decade,
and global economy would thrive.
So, economically, it's not going to
be the big issue that you might think.
And actually, also, you
mentioned population.
If you do the numbers,
sure, if nobody ever
dies, that's a problem,
and I wouldn't even say that's
something I'm trying to do.
But am I trying to give people
more health and prevent suffering?
Absolutely.
And actually, even if we
stopped anyone dying today,
the rate of population growth
would be less than immigration in the U.S.
So, it's not going to ruin
the world any time soon.
We have bigger problems
to worry about than that.
And I think by saving
these trillions of dollars,
that's money that can
be put towards solving
the problems that we really
need to solve right now
in housing, unemployment,
and climate change.
- Right, and you mentioned it in the book,
but the kind of crowding
issue is much more of a
not only just lifespan,
but there's reproduction,
and there's good argument that
as people become wealthier
and more economically productive,
those are the countries
that are actually having
shrinking populations.
So yeah, it's a fascinating...
What is your...
Well, I'm sure people...
Well, I don't know if
you mind me saying this.
For those who don't know, my wife and I,
my wife, Umaima, and I met David
at a conference a couple of years ago.
And I had been following
his work for a long time,
so I was very excited to meet him.
We started chatting.
And I know this is kind of a
flip dimension of all of this.
You're a serious researcher.
But you're clearly doing something right.
Anyone looking at the screen right now
would assume that I'm like
10 years older than you.
- No.
- But I think you're 10
years older than me. (laughs)
- Well, I just turned 51, but
I haven't shaved in a while
and haven't had a haircut in a while.
But thank you for saying that.
Yeah, I mean, we'll see.
I think the proof is in the pudding,
and I'm trying to
live the life that I
think is the healthiest,
as a role model.
If I didn't do what I'm
telling others to do,
it would be hypocritical.
So I try to exercise. I try to eat well.
I try to, if I can, skip breakfast
and even have a late lunch.
My father does something
very similar, and we'll see.
Neither of us is sick at all.
My father's 80, close to 81,
and as vibrant as ever.
I think he's even stronger than me
the last time we checked.
But you know, I'm not
trying to prove anything.
I'm not worried about dying myself.
I'm just curious to see what happens,
and I'm measuring things in myself
to try and gain insights into
what works and what doesn't.
- And this is, and look,
I'll give the same disclaimer
I've given several times.
Neither of us are doctors.
Neither of us are trying to give advice
or sell pharmaceuticals, et cetera.
But I am curious.
I mean, you mentioned you
do a few things, actually,
and we have that in common.
I also do intermittent fasting.
As we speak, I haven't
eaten for about 20 years.
So, I do that.
I've actually recently become pescatarian.
I like fish a lot,
so that's taking me a little
bit harder to let go of.
So, I try to do a lot of these
things, and you're right.
Regardless of what it does to
lifespan, I just feel better.
I feel healthier.
I have much more mental
clarity during the day,
actually in a fasted state.
Once again, not medical advice.
Don't do it while you're growing, kids,
but when you're an adult,
you can think about it.
Read the research. Decide for yourself.
What other things do you,
I mean, or at least would
you recommend people research
and make a decision for
themselves if it makes sense,
or you know other people
in the field that think,
"Yeah, this is probably a good idea.
"It might make sense."
- Well, yeah, the exercise
is the other thing
besides eating less.
And again, you know,
we're not talking about
malnutrition, starvation.
No. You need a healthy diet.
And you can make up for
it with your other meals.
But what we find in
animals, and in humans,
is that being hungry for
a little part of the day
turns on these defenses.
But exercise, let's turn to that.
Right in front of me, you
can't see this, anybody,
but I have a gym, which
is attached to my bedroom.
I'm sure-
- That's hardcore.
You have a gym attached to your bedroom.
- I do. I should use it more often.
But yeah, I do. I do try to workout.
I've got a treadmill. I've got weights.
And looking at my father,
who's been doing this for
many more years than I have,
it's essential for health in your old age.
And it's not just about
maintaining your muscle mass,
which is, of course, you
lose that as you get older.
It's also flexibility.
So if you fall over, you'll bounce,
and you also won't tear anything,
and that's just as important.
So, keep that flexibility.
Keep the muscle strength up.
But also, if you exercise just for,
it's been shown just for 10 minutes a day,
lose your breath,
that will also activate
these longevity pathways,
these genes that I talk about.
And so, it doesn't take that much.
You don't need to be a marathon runner
to get a lot of the benefits
we're talking about.
- And I've read about that as well,
and actually, a lot of trainers these days
advocate it with these
high-intensity training.
What you just said was interesting.
You said lose your breath.
That's kind of what you see
as one of the key factors?
Is there some evidence
that when you get winded,
that stimulates some of these pathways?
- Right, that seems to be the case.
Just walking will be good for you,
but yeah, if you can just get hypoxia,
going to lack of oxygen,
then you stimulate all sorts of things,
like boosting those
energy-producing mitochondria.
And it's borne out in
studies of people who,
particularly elderly people get studied.
There's a great place down
in University of Florida
where they test what's
good for older people,
and it is very clear
that losing your breath
is the best thing.
I don't find it pleasant,
losing my breath.
Some people do, but I'm not in that camp.
So, I push sleds when I'm at the gym.
I try to run a little bit.
That's the least you should do, actually.
- I just find these conversations-
Oh, we're already over time,
but I have one last question.
Because, obviously we're
having this conversation
about health and aging
in a time where there's a global pandemic.
And you touched on it a little bit
that molecules like NAD might
have a benefit in COVID.
And COVID is an example that
has clear age correlations,
where as far as I know there's
zero or a handful of cases
of children being
seriously sick from COVID,
and the risks just go up
exponentially as you get older.
What do you understand?
How much have you directly studied COVID?
What do you understand about it?
Why do you think it has such
a strong age correlation?
Essentially, kids don't get it,
or they get it, but they
don't have any of the real,
the bad symptoms.
- Yeah.
So, I wrote a review on this
which I think is fairly
available to anybody.
So, if you google my name,
you should be able to read about it.
There are lots of explanations,
or potential explanations.
I don't think anybody really knows.
There's everything from changes
to how proteins are modified,
through to exhaustion of our
immune system as we get older.
Even having lots of viral infections
during our lifetime can exhaust that.
Part of the possible
explanation does include NAD.
A lot of people probably roll their eyes.
You know, "Can Sinclair talk
about anything else but NAD?"
And during the beginning of the pandemic,
I resisted really trying to
figure out if NAD had a role,
but more and more evidence came up.
So, we've had a study in my
lab for the last few years
that shows that NAD depletion occurs,
a lack of NAD occurs when
there's an infection.
That's one bit of evidence.
But then there was another
study, Charlie Brenner,
a professor showed that
patient samples actually have low NAD
if they have bad COVID infection.
And then there are some case studies
coming out of Cedars-Sinai Hospital
with patients that did remarkably well
given an NAD booster cocktail.
So, all of that led me to
look more and more into it.
And it turns out that my lab,
and now Charlie's lab has also shown
that the virus is
depleting NAD in the body.
It does that for reasons
we're not really sure,
but it might be part of the
pathogenesis, as we call it,
part of the problem that the virus causes.
And so the hope, and
we're testing this now,
hopefully soon in patients,
is that by getting that NAD
depletion back up to normal
that elderly people will have the energy
and the immune system to
be able to fight the virus.
And there's another
thing that's interesting,
is that that hyperinflammation
where these severe cases actually succumb
to over-inflammation,
or the cytokine storm,
that we know that if you have less NAD,
you get this hyperactivation.
And so, that's another
possible way that NAD boosting
could actually help
people with a very extreme
late stage form of COVID-19.
- So, that's interesting,
because when you see the
cytokine storm, as you mentioned,
that's when inflammation,
that's your immune system,
is going and attacking a bunch of stuff.
Cytokines are cells in your immune system.
And that's one of the
causes of severe illness
or even death of COVID.
It's actually because...
It's associated when people have low NAD,
they're more likely to
have a cytokine storm.
That seems counterintuitive,
because I always associate NAD
with ATP production and metabolism,
but that you can be overactive.
Is my intuition off, or?
- Well, the critical determinant of this
is called the inflammasome,
and there's a protein called NLRP3,
and a couple of labs have shown
that NAD levels directly control
the activity of that protein
and that if you don't have enough NAD,
that inflammasome complex goes berserk,
and then one thing leads to another
and you can't switch it off.
So, it hasn't been proven
in humans, of course,
but in cells and in mice it has been shown
that low NAD in those older animals
leads to this hyperactivation.
- Wow. Wow.
Well, I could, as you know,
you probably had trouble
getting away from me
when I met you a couple of years ago.
We could talk for hours,
but we're already well
over the scheduled time.
But thank you so much, David,
for joining and having this conversation,
which I, clearly, am deeply intrigued by.
- Well, Sal, it's great to see you again,
and thanks for having me on.
- Yeah.
Well, thanks everyone for
joining today, as always.
Fascinating conversation.
I wasn't joking when I said
I followed David's work
for many decades and have
his book right over there.
I recommend folks to take a look at it
if you've been intrigued
by this conversation.
It's called "Lifespan".
But I look forward to seeing you in,
I think, is it day after
tomorrow or tomorrow?
Let me see. I have it on the...
Oh, there you go, tomorrow.
Felipe is right there for me.
So, I'll be tomorrow
with an ask me anything.
And then on Thursday we're
gonna have Jacquelline Fuller,
the vice president and president-
vice president of Google
and president of Google.org
to talk about all of the work
they do around the world,
including some of which
is actually helping us
do our work at Khan Academy.
Thanks everyone for joining,
and I will see you tomorrow,
and then on Thursday.